what an amazing night the b-e-t awards
were the first award show that really
felt like a real award show again
shout out to jesse collins who produced
the show everybody at b-e-t and oh
cardi who gave us even more than we were
expecting
[Music]
cardi b stunned the crowd in a bedazzled
belly-bearing dolce
gabbana onesie fans couldn't help but
compare it to this
iconic beyonce moment from the vmas in
2011.
cardi performed with husband offset and
his group migos
what will we see tonight uh the most
electrifying show on earth
is cardi getting a check as the fourth
migos because she's doing all those
videos
you know my baby boss herself you know
i'm saying cardi also instagramed this
baby bump profile
covered in white paint the 28-year-old
won video of the year with megan the
stallion
who had a huge night make the stallions
meg took home four awards including best
female hip-hop artist
performing twice in a platinum blonde
wig i'm
trying to win the rapper fought back
tears thanking her mother who passed
away in 2019.
i still think about her every day and
she's the reason why i keep going
oh you know i always wanted you her who
is already a grammy and oscar winner
this year
won best female r b pop artist she
electrified the crowd showcasing her
drumming
and guitar skills as she celebrated her
24th birthday
what am i doing for my birthday i'm
going to kill the stage speaking of
killing it
[Applause]
little nazex dazzled with this ancient
egypt performance a nod to michael
jackson's remember the time
you know the really cool thing about
this year's bet awards is that everyone
was
back in person there was a red carpet it
felt like a family getting back together
bruno mars in anderson pack known as
silk sonic performed up close to
vaccinated fans
bt's president told me the show required
an incredible amount of planning
and teamwork we're the first kind of
postcoded
show live show we have more performances
this year than in any of the 21 years of
the show
hit records are getting shorter so it
just allowed
us to squeeze in more performances than
we've ever had where my dogs at
the show closed with the powerhouse
tribute to the legendary rapper dmx
who passed away in april
busta rhymes method man swizz beats and
members of the rough riders crew
all took to the stage i think i'm
slipping i'm falling i can't get up
the wires emmy-nominated actor michael k
williams joined for slipping
he was so spot on he became a fan
favorite to play dmx in a potential
biopic
[Music]
i've always put a kindred spirit to that
brother
the late chadwick boseman was honored
during the stars we lost tribute
alongside the iconic cecily tyson
bozeman also won best actor which marks
his 44th posthumous acting award
[Music]
queen latifah received the lifetime
achievement award she gave an emotional
speech on stage with her father
while holding on to a photograph of her
late mother i've always
celebrated the woman because i was
raised
by a strong black woman peace
happy pride
[Applause]
little kim money love m.c light and
rhapsody took the stage and performed a
show-stopping medley in honor of their
queen
latifah paved the way for me latifah
you're just everything and i spoke to
presenter jennifer hudson
who's gearing up for her tribute to the
queen of soul in the biopic respect out
august 13th
[Music]
aretha hand-picked you no pressure but
she hand-picked you
a lot a lot of pressure enough with her
saying jennifer do this but
they gave me the strength and
encouragement to try
[Music]
last night andrew day walked away with
the best actress award for playing
billie holiday two months after losing
out at the oscars where one wild romance
rumor started was it weird to
wake up and look and everyone is saying
you're dating brad pitt
was that that i was like especially
because we never met so i was like oh
all right
we're not dating we don't even know each
other somebody was bored that day
they sure were i'm just great though
super talented wonderful
andrew quick changed to sheer green for
her performance but
nobody was in more outfits than
first-time host taraji p henson i have
an incredible entrance taraji p henson
that is gonna knock your socks off i am
also gonna be dressed like
five women that i really love and admire
some past some presents from dressing
like her
and singer erica badu to icons like
betty boop inspiration esther jones
tina turner and diana ross taraji did
not disappoint
backstage she busted out some lyrics
about her dedication
dresses to fit because i wasn't drinking
no
eating taraji started the night in
versace same as zendaya who paid tribute
to a queen
queen b the actress slash
singer was six when beyonce performed at
the 2003 bet awards
in this purple bodice with wild cutouts
zendaya's homage
worthy of this backyard strut
but are two female rappers about to bury
their beef with a versus battle is there
anybody that you would do it again so
you just ready for anybody
nikki that would be nicki minaj who
dropped several little kim diss tracks
after she once called nikki a clone and
a wannabe nikki
really i would love to see that yes me
[Music]
too